a couple of new adapted monsters from
the original scary stories book trilogy
have been revealed in the new trailer so
if you want to hear about those then
stick around to the end of this video
but first I've been waiting all winter
to hang this baby back up so the new
scary stories trailer contains a mix of
new footage and stuff that we've seen
before in the Superbowl trailers if
you're sitting there wondering why
haven't I seen that footage what are you
talking about it could be because you're
not subscribed with death Bell
notifications on so the trailer starts
as many movie trailers do establishing
the setting 1960s Mill Valley
Pennsylvania our characters discover a
spooky house and go inside where we see
our first thing you missed yeah we got a
counter now because I ran a poll and you
guys said yeah you might as well put a
counter the rooms lit by candle lights
and this whole situation is probably a
reference to the curse a story for more
scary stories to tell in the dark in
which some college kids are doing a frat
initiation where they must explore this
deserted house with a candle the other
students watch from outside where they
see that each pledge who attempts the
Dare disappears after their candle goes
out on the third floor eventually they
all go up to investigate thinking it was
some kind of prank but they find nothing
with a no sign of the disappeared
students every year since then a frat
member has died or gone crazy and the
writer of the story is the only one left
remaining my guess is that this college
initiation was changed to a high school
dare to better fit the characters of
this movie the kids in the movie find
this book and it seems that the scary
stories from the book start to come true
and haunt their town I'm guessing that
this is one of the illustrations found
in that book not quite as creepy as some
of the illustrations from the actual
book trilogy that this movie is based on
but still kind of creepy to find an old
picture containing a headless sailor
just standing there it looks like
they're going to be combining tales from
different stories
headless Ness is one of the most common
themes found in the books as somebody
loses their head in literally six
different short stories may I carry your
basket air until
Oh Susanna the brown suit it's him and
the iconic meet I'd see walk but the
Sailor outfit can only points to one
story called somebody fell from aloft
about a mysterious body that falls onto
a ship on an oversea voyage if you pause
on the next image you'll see that may I
carry your basket and somebody fell from
aloft are right next to each other in
the movie version of the book despite
the fact that they aren't even in the
same book in real life there's one short
story that's generally regarded the
highest by fans and that is Harold the
tale of two farmers who make a scarecrow
and named it after another farmer Harold
that they don't like the Scarecrow
becomes a punching bag for them whenever
they need to let off some steam but
eventually they start to notice that
Harold is making grunting noises growing
and eventually walking around on their
roof indy skinning his victims the
trailer shows the ominous cornfield
Harold's possibly watching one of the
farmers and Harold's angry expression as
his face crawls with cockroaches this
looks like it's gonna be even creepier
than the story that it's based on
another story that I think we'll see is
called the bed by the window in the
trailer we see the kids approaching this
hospital and in the story patients who
have the bed next to the window keep
dying one man who moves into the bed
keeps describing how amazing the window
view is so this other guy named George
ends up murdering him in his sleep so
that he can move into the bed with the
window view but when he gets there all
he can see is a brick wall since the
movie is gonna be combining stories I
think the hallway scene where we see the
pale skinned lady from the dream could
be at that same hospital I believe in
the last video I speculated that it
might have been at their high school by
the way if you want to hear my analysis
of the pale skinned lady in the big toe
creature the red spots or the gangly boy
I go more in depth about those in my
scary stories to user analysis video
which you can check out right here the
trailer also features a police officer
character which is probably a smart
choice considering that there's at least
five stories in the book where the cops
get involved there's high beams in which
they arrest a man found hiding in the
back of a girl's truck with a knife the
babysitter in which they arrest an
intruder hiding in an attic the Viper in
which a paranoid man alerts the police
of some suspicious phone calls but it
turns out to just be a German janitor
who wants to vie his windows by the look
of things I could use a viper right
about now myself
then there's the window not to be
confused with the previously mentioned
the bed by the
window where the police are called after
our vampire breaks into someone's house
through the window even though that's
not typically allowed with the vampires
and finally the trouble this one has the
most police involvement it's about a
house that seemingly possessed by a
poltergeist and the stubborn detective
tries his best to find a rational
explanation for everything that's
happened this cops jailhouse looks to
play a significant role as the home of
the monster from the thing the
characters in that story describe a
strange creature crawling out of a
turnip field at first it looks like some
kind of weird animal but then they
realize that it's vaguely human this
might be the creepiest image in the
trailer actually if you slow it down and
get a good look at the things face I'm
sure they'll probably be some weirdo in
the comments though who thinks he's cute
there's one more new creature at the
very end of the trailer now there are
several ghosts throughout the series but
I think this is the ghost from the
haunted house a story from the first
book it's about a preacher who tries to
put an uneasy spirit to rest he hears
murderous sounds within the house before
the ghost eventually approaches him and
tells him the story of how her lover
killed her for her money and hid her
body in the cellar she wants him to give
her a proper burial and use her detached
finger to find her killer
he puts the finger in the collection
plate at church and it sticks to the man
who murdered her he confesses to his
crimes and so the ghost tells the
preacher where to find the hidden money
but the spots where the ghost initially
grabbed his coat has her finger marks
permanently burned into the clock I'm
gonna keep you up-to-date on any things
you might have missed in future teasers
and trailers for scary stories to tell
in the dark by the way how many was that
okay so that's how many there were no
more comments questioning the number of
things you missed that just leaves the
comments saying you don't know what I
missed how dare you assume what I missed
if you haven't seen the video on the
left watch that to see about the other
creatures that I didn't cover in this
video and remember to subscribe to seize
these worlds for new Horrors every week
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next episode
assuming we both survive
you